- On les prépare comme
s'ils allaient à la guerre.
Ils ne sont ni médecin ni
infirmier, mais de simples
bénévoles en formation qui ont
répondu à l'appel de leur Église
pour aller aider un système
de santé catastrophé.
"C'est comme un film
d'horreur", dit Peter Simchenko.
Il enfile, cinq soirs semaine,
une combinaison pour se jeter
dans la gueule du loup :
les zones rouges des hôpitaux
COVID de toute la région
de Moscou.
- We see suffering.
We see hope.
- Ces bénévoles offrent
du soutien à ceux qui peinent
à respirer. On ne sait jamais
qui sera le prochain.
"C'est terrifiant parce que
c'est l'inconnu", dit Elisaveta,
une des 10 nouvelles recrues
qui écoutent les consignes
attentivement, mais avec
la peur dans les yeux.
"Je les prépare
aussi psychologiquement,
dit l'infirmière,
et je leur demande surtout
de faire preuve d'empathie,
peu importe la situation."
"Car 100 % des cas critiques
sont des patients non vaccinés
qui auraient pu s'en sortir",
dit le Dr Denisov.
Il a consacré sa pause
pour nous expliquer à quel
point le variant est dangereux.
Avant, il fallait une semaine
pour que leur santé se
détériore; maintenant; c'est en
deux ou trois jours qu'ils sont
placés sous respirateur.
Reste qu'à Moscou,
les patients ont de
la chance dans leur malheur.
Dans certaines régions,
c'est dans les corridors
que les malades dépérissent.
Des médecins à qui nous avons
parlé et qui n'ont pas le droit
de le dire à la caméra
nous confirment qu'il manque
cruellement d'oxygène
et qu'il faut laisser
les gens mourir.
L'oxygène, cette précieuse
denrée, les hôpitaux vont
désormais la chercher
là où ils peuvent.
Même celle qui sert de
carburant aux fusée russes
est mise à contribution.
"Nous avons décidé de suspendre
les tests de tir des moteurs de
fusée", a confirmé le directeur
de l'agence spatiale.
Comment un pays qui a développé
le tout premier vaccin au monde
a pu en arriver là?
Le directeur du fonds
d'investissement qui
commercialise le vaccin
n'a pas voulu répondre
à notre question lors
d'une conférence de presse
virtuelle où il vantait
l'efficacité d'un nouveau
vaccin, le Sputnik Light,
comme piqûre de rappel.
Mais ici, vacciné ou pas,
la vie continue, souvent
comme si de rien était.
Le taux de vaccination demeure
obstinément bas, à peine 29 %.
Comme tant d'autres, Natalia
refuse de se faire vacciner
ou de porter un masque.
"C'est de l'égoïsme et
de la désinvolture", dit Peter.
"Mais j'essaie de garder
mon sens de l'humour."
"Et à ces gens-là,
je leur dis : on se reverra
dans la zone rouge."
Et comme avant chaque session
de formation, les bénévoles
se recueillent pour que
le bon Dieu les protège...
... mais les prières
ne suffisent plus pour
surmonter cette quatrième vague.
Ici Tamara Alteresco,
Radio-Canada, Mosco